Mark Andreessen has helped a lot of
people get rich including Mark
Andreessen and he's made millions of
people's lives more fun more efficient
or just a little weirder
he's the co-creator of the first widely
used web browser he's the co-founder of
the Venture Capital Powerhouse Andresen
Horowitz
and though he hates the industry term
unicorn for a private Tech firm valued
at more than a billion dollars he's a
famously successful unicorn Wrangler he
was an early investor in Facebook
Pinterest LinkedIn Twitter Lyft and more
Andresen is also aggressively quotable
whether it's his classic 2011
pronouncement that software is eating
the world or his more recent there are
no bad ideas only early ones and in 2014
he said in 20 years we'll be talking
about Bitcoin the way we talk about the
internet today a born Bull and Jason is
an optimist who places his hope for the
future squarely in the hands of the 19
year olds and the startups no one has
heard of as splashy AI such as Chachi PT
and Dali begin to permeate our daily
lives and the predictable Panic revs up
reason sat down with Andresen to talk
about what the future will look like
whether it's still going to emerge from
Silicon Valley about the role of
government in fostering or destroying
Innovation and what you should read on
your next Beach vacation
[Music]
so let's start with AI
um I tend to be skeptical on a pretty
basic level of people who want to claim
that this time it's different with any
given Tech or cultural Trend but I guess
what I want to start with is is This
Time It's Different
yeah can I do can I do the long can I do
the long answer absolutely it's okay
good so so look the long answer is like
you know AI has been kind of the
fundamental dream of computer science
going all the way back to the 1940s
right so uh Ellen Turing Alan Turing
used to be this obscure historical
figure and then they made the movie The
imitation game uh which I I hear is a
great movie um which has made it more
famous and uh you know he was sort of
one of the you know there are a bunch of
these guys but there were a bunch of
guys back then who sort of invented the
computer as as we know it today you know
and it was during the heat the heat of
World War II but but even in the very
beginning you know they just had this
you know in this the you know human
beings I think can't resist
anthropomorphizing everything and so he
had this kind of you know feeling right
he's sort of drive right up front saying
like let's let's build an electronic
brain right let's let's let's build
artificial intelligence and so he and
John Von Neumann and Claude Shannon and
a lot of those guys in that era you know
kind of were thinking about this you
know and this is literally when they're
like wiring the first computers together
right and the computers that they were
working with in those days they were
running out of vacuum tubes right and
and they they literally would hand wire
the computers together like they were
and soldering the connections um you
know the term computer bug actually
comes from the fact that the problem
that they had in those days was not a
software bug as we understand it today
the problem they would have is that an
actual insect would fly into the wiring
uh and would fry
um and then that would actually short
out the computer
um and so that's why that's why computer
problems are called bugs
so anyway this has been a dream you know
going all the way back to that era and
then basically the field of computer
science has always had this AI you know
kind of specialty in it basically for
it's like 78 years now right um and you
know to your point like repeatedly there
was like this dream that you know it was
finally about to happen
um there were it depends how you count
like five or six like AI booms where
people were really convinced that like
this time it's the time it's going to
happen
um and then they were what in the field
of referred to as the AI Winters right
in which it turns out like oops you know
not yet
um but I mean if you think about it 78
years like there were AI researchers who
literally were born went to college got
their phds worked in the field their
entire career and died
kind of in that period without ever
actually seeing the results of all of
their work
um and so it's one of these things where
like you know you know it's like you
know it's like one of these things it's
like it's like you know you know Isaac
Newton spent a lot of his time pursuing
Alchemy right um and it's like you know
maybe you know there are some things
that these people kind of spend you know
decades on or or even longer and they
never work and then there are some
things that are you know 78 year you
know overnight successes like sometimes
these things actually do work
um and so um yeah so so you know this
let's say for for sure we're in another
one of those AI booms it's like AI boom
number five or six or seven
um for sure there's this Rush of
enthusiasm um but there's a couple
things that are different about what's
happening right now um and the the big
thing that's different um is that there
are these like very well-defined tests
ways of sort of measuring sort of
intelligence-like capabilities let's say
um and uh computers have started to do
actually better than people
um on these tests and these are tests
that involve kind of interactions with
fuzzy reality right so these aren't just
tests of like can you do math faster
these are tests of like can you process
reality in a superior way
um and so the first of those test
breakthroughs was in 2012 when computers
became better than human beings at
recognizing images in uh recognizing
objects and images right so you like
throw up a whole bunch of images a whole
bunch of photographs right and it's like
is this you know the use the internet
meme is this a cat right or is this like
a you know cinnamon bun right or is this
you know something else
um and computers aren't now actually
better at doing that kind of object
recognition and images at scale that
people are that that's the Breakthrough
that has made the self-driving car a
real possibility right because the
because with the self-driving cars is
basically just processing large amounts
of images and trying to understand you
know is that a kid running across the
street or is that a plastic bag right
and should I hit the brakes or should I
just keep going
um and and self-driving cars are
starting to work like Tesla's you know
full self-driving isn't perfect yet but
it's starting to work quite well and
then um you know waymo um uh one of our
companies you know you know they're up
and running now
um it's something that people can people
can experience and so so that's starting
to happen and then
we started to see kind of these
breakthroughs in natural what's called
natural language processing about five
years ago where computers started
getting really good at understanding
um written English they started actually
getting very good at speech synthesis
which is actually quite an a challenging
problem itself and then most recently
there's this huge breakthrough you know
in uh you know in the the products have
sort of come to Market called chat GPT
or you know more generally this
phenomenon it's chat GPT is a is an
instance of a broader phenomenon in the
field called large language models or
llms
um and you know people presumably like I
don't know a lot of people have now
tried this and so they've had hands-on
experience with this and I'll just tell
you like a lot of people outside the
tech industry are shocked by what that
thing can do and I'll just tell you A
lot of people inside the tech industry
are shocked by what that thing can do
um and so you know it feels like yeah
yeah I was actually going to ask that
because Chad GPT does feel to those of
us who don't fundamentally understand
what's going on like a little bit of a a
party trick or a magic trick right and
sometimes it's the sort of classic
technology sufficiently advanced is
indistinguishable from Magic and
sometimes it it really is a trick
um but
um you know you're saying no no this is
this is something real we can see
something real underneath well so it's
also a trick
so it's both right so this is why it's
such this is why your question is such
an interesting question right this is
actually a very kind of big profound
there's a big profound underlying
question we're going to get to which is
what does it mean to be smart like what
what does it mean to be conscious what
does it mean to be human like right like
ultimately all the big questions are not
what does the machine do ultimately all
the big questions are what do we do
right
um and and so the the big underlying
question under all this is like what do
we do like how do how do we actually
like form sentences how do we actually
make arguments how do we actually like
write screenplays and like write poetry
and like do all the things we do and
like how much of what we do as a trick
and so we'll we'll come back to that in
a second but but look so let me let me
describe what what llms you know what
these things actually are like like chat
GPT so so what
so what they actually are is they're
basically very fancy autocompletes
um right and so autocomplete is like a
standard computer function if you have
an iPhone right whatever it happens you
know you start typing a word and it will
offer you an auto completion right of
the rest of that word so you don't have
to type the whole word
um and then you know Google Gmail has
autocomplete now for sentences um where
you start typing a sentence Oh I'm sorry
I can't make it to your event and it
will kind of it'll suggest the rest of
the sentence
um and and so basically what what llms
are is basically autocomplete across a
paragraph or across five paragraphs
right or or by the way maybe a
autocomplete across 20 Pages or in the
future by the way maybe it autocomplete
across an entire book right like in
other words like you should close your
eyes and imagine a future version of
this thing right you sit down to write
your next book this literally something
is going to happen you'll sit down and
write your next book you'll type the
first sentence and it will suggest the
rest of the book
right now are you going to want what it
suggested maybe right when we'll come
back to scenarios where that might be
the case uh probably not but it's going
to give you a suggestion right and it's
going to give you a suggestion it's
going to give you suggested chapters
it's going to give you suggested topics
it's going to give you suggested
examples it's going to get you you know
suggested you know ways to word things
you know you're gonna you can already do
this with chat GPT you can type in it's
like look here you know here's my draft
like here you know here's you know
here's five paragraphs I just wrote um
you know how how could this be worded
better
um how could this be worded more simply
um how could this be worded in a way
that people who are younger can
understand it right and so it's going to
be able to auto complete kind of in all
of these kind of very interesting ways
and then it's it and then it's up to the
human being who's steering it to decide
um you know what to do with that and and
so this is kind of my point right is is
that a trick or is that a breakthrough
right the answer is like yes to both
like yes it's a trick like in other
words well here's a critique here's a
critique of um there's a critique of
llms and so there's there's this guy Jan
lacun who's a legend in the field of AI
who's who's at uh at meta and he's been
he's been tweeting this publicly he's
his Twitter account's gotten very active
lately
um and uh he's like look he's like he's
arguing he argues this is more trick
than breakthrough and he argues
basically it's like look this thing
autocompletes right it's like a puppy it
like Auto completes the text it thinks
you want to see but it doesn't actually
understand any of the things that it's
saying like it doesn't actually know who
people are it doesn't know how physics
works it doesn't know how math works
right like it doesn't like it and it has
this thing that's called hallucination
in the field where like if it doesn't
have an autocomplete it's like fastly
correct it's like a puppy it still wants
to make you happy and so it will
autocomplete a hallucination and it will
it'll start making up like names and
dates and historical events that never
happened yeah well the thing that that
always sounds like to me I know the term
is hallucination the thing that it
always connects with to me is imposter
syndrome I mean it it sounds like
you know I I don't know whether humans
have the Imposter syndrome or the AIS do
but we're all just saying the thing that
we think
someone wants to hear
so so this goes to the underlying
question which is what do people do
right and then this is where things get
like incredibly uncomfortable like for
you know for a lot of people to think
about this which is like okay like like
what is human consciousness like how do
we form ideas like how do we decide I
mean I I I don't know about you what
I've found in my life is that number one
a lot of people in a day-to-day basis
are just telling you what they think you
want to hear right and and it's just and
for a lot of people it's just much more
for you than For Me
Maybe although you know look a lot of
this just you know walking down the
street or working with you know working
with anybody in a professional context
or you know working you know work with
the customers you know take you know buy
buy a buy a coat and then take it back
next week and complain to the customer
service rep right the customer service
rep you know they're thinking wow you
know this person is a real you know
whatever like but they're not saying
that like they're saying oh I'm so sorry
you know Miss customer you know how can
I help you right so so life is full of
these like life is full of these
autocompletes
kind of as is and then look like you
know you see this in intellectual debate
like an intellectual debate I mean you
guys you know live live this life like
how many people are making arguments
that they actually have conceived of
right um and that they actually believe
versus how many people are making
arguments any intellectual debate that
are basically the arguments that they
think people are expecting them to make
right and you know this is where you see
this thing in politics where basically
it's this weird thing in politics that
you guys are kind of an exception to as
we're thinking of politics where most
people have the exact same sets of views
as everybody else on their side on every
conceivable issue right um right it
isn't that a coincidence every time how
that happens every single time right and
it's like well and you know what do we
know we know that those people have not
sat down and thought through all of
those issues from first principle and
they we know that they haven't
automatically arrived at all the same
views we know this was what's happened
of course is a social reinforcement
mechanism right so people are saying
what they what they what they think is
necessary to fit into society
so is that actually any better than the
machine essentially trying to do the
same thing like I I think it's kind of
the same like so I think what we're
going to learn is that we're a lot more
like GPT than we thought right well so
there's another another way to come at
this which is uh there's this thing
called the Turing test right so Alan
Turing I mentioned he he's sort of early
on he created this this thing called the
Turing test
um and the Turing test was basically his
his attempt to basically said look if
let's suppose we develop what we think
is an AI let's suppose we develop a
program and we think it's it's smart in
the same way that a person is smart um
and you know how will we know that it's
actually smart and so he proposed this
thing called the Turing test and in the
Turing test basically you have a human
subject and then they're in a chat room
and they're in a chat room with a human
being and with a computer
um and both the human being and the
computer they're in the chat room with
are trying to convince them that they're
actually the real person that the other
one is the computer right um and then
basically and then the question is
basically is the computer as good as or
better than the person right the other
person at convincing the subject that
they're actually human being right and
so the theory there basically is the
test is if a computer can convince you
that it's a human being that then it
effectively is AI like it's it's it's
every bit as intelligence intelligent
Essentia and conscious as a as a as a
human
the obvious problem with the Turing test
right is that we're really people are
really easy to trick right we're like
super easy to con right and like life is
filled with like you know everybody's
life is filled with people trying to con
them every time you watch a TV
commercial they're trying to you know
con you every time you talk to a
salesperson you know there's just this
constant not you know every time you're
you know three card Monty you know you
know magician doing a card trick
politician on TV right they're always
trying to con you in some way and we
know you know we know that human beings
are like relatively susceptible to being
kind and so a computer that's good at
pawning you right it is that actually
like is that AI or is that just
basically revealing an underlying
weakness in actually what we think of as
that which is profoundly human which is
like we're really easy to trick and if
we're that easy to trick it's like okay
well how smart are we
right and so I I think you see what I'm
saying like it's there's no single
there's no single Vector of like smart
versus non-smart it's more like okay
there's certain sets of things that
people can do better or worse
um there's certain sets of things
computers can do better for worse you
know better or worse um the things
computers can do that are better are
getting really good um I mean art
another way to think about this if you
try like mid-journey or dolly or these
new uh AI art generating things but like
you know these things now like at their
best they're generating art that is I
think pretty clearly let's say um
you know aesthetically Superior is like
a very deep uh thing but let's just say
more beautiful like they're able to
produce art that is more beautiful than
all but maybe a handful of human artists
like just objectively you look at and
you're like wow that's beautiful
um and so you know two years ago did we
expect did we expect a computer to make
to be making beautiful art no we didn't
can it do it now routinely yes what does
that mean in terms of what human artists
do like if there's only a few human
artists that can produce art that
beautiful maybe we're not that good at
making art maybe you know you see what
I'm saying yeah so I think a lot of you
know you've been sort of using the
language of humanity like humans are
like this humans have these attributes
um but some of this at least is cultural
and the question it raises for me is one
that I think is also kind of a political
question
how much does it matter where these AIS
emerge like should we care if AIS are
American or coming out of Silicon Valley
versus coming from another cultural
place
so I think we should
so among the things that we're talking
about here are the among the things
we're talking about in the future of
warfare right so you know what isn't it
you know you can see at the self-driving
car like if you have a self-driving car
that means you can have a self-flying
plane right that means you can have a
self-guided submarine right that means
you can have like you know smart drought
you could have you know you have this
concept now we see in Ukraine with the
so-called loiter Munitions right which
is basically a suicide drone it's a it's
a it's a it's a drone that's a suicide
bomb basically suicide being that it
kills itself
um but it just like stays in the sky
until it sees a Target and it just like
zeros in and you know drops a grenade or
it itself is the bomb
um and so this whole like the the whole
era the whole era I mean I just watched
the new Top Gun movie right um and like
and they kind of they alluded to this a
little bit in the movie which is it's
like a human being you know to train an
F-16 or F-18 like fighter pilot right um
is like you know I don't know seven
eight ten fifteen million dollars plus
it's a it's a you know a very valuable
human being
um and you know we put these people in
these tin cans and then we fly them
through the air at you know whatever
mock whatever and then you know they
actually do a good job of the movie of
like the GeForce issue right which is
like there's you know the plane is
capable of maneuvering in ways it will
actually kill the pilot
um and so what the plane can do is
actually constrained by what the what
the what the human body can actually put
up with and then by the way the the
plane that is capable of sustaining
human life is like very big and
expensive right and has all these
systems to be able to accommodate the
human pilot look a supersonic AI drone
is not going to have any of those
restraints right so first of all it's
going to cost a fraction of the price
right second is it can be you know much
smaller or by the way much bigger it
doesn't need to have even the shape that
we are associate today with like it
could have any shape that's aerodynamic
right it doesn't need to like take into
account you know human pilot it can fly
faster it can maneuver faster it can do
all kinds of turns right and you know
acceleration all kinds of things that
human the human uh Pilot's body can't
tolerate it can make decisions much more
quickly you know it can generate much
more information you know per second
than any human being Can it can make you
know decisions very fast and then by the
way
you're not just going to have one of
those like you're going to have you know
at a time you're going to have 10 or 100
or a thousand or ten thousand or a
hundred thousand of those things flying
at the same time right and so these
things are going to come out of the sky
in swarms um there's a there's one movie
that has gotten this right it's a it's a
movie it's an action movie uh Gerard
Butler it's called Uh uh Angel has
fallen um and uh in the opening scene uh
there's a terror attack against the the
US president and the movie played by of
course Morgan Freeman
um is uh fishing
um on this big beautiful Lake and he's
got all these you know Secret Service
guys around
um and uh all of a sudden there's what
looked like a flock of birds you know
big flock of birds coming from the
distance and it turns out they're you
know suicide drones
um and the movie does a really good job
of showing like what that kind of attack
is going to be like
um and it's like this is all like this
is all underway like this is this is all
happening this is all going to happen
like this is just very very clear it's
very obvious
um it's gonna happen very broadly you
know look the the the the nation states
with the best AI capabilities are going
to have the best defense capabilities by
the way the dod's already on this the
dod the Department of Defense in the US
has already clear that AI is what they
call the third offset which is basically
means the future of warfare right so
they're going to completely rotate how
they spend money
um and so like this is it like future
you know if there's ever if there's ever
I mean God forbid but if there's ever
war between the US and China like this
is the form that it's going to take
um and so yeah it's going to matter you
know it's like asking who had the atomic
bomb like it's going to matter a great
deal
do you think uh like I think that that's
you know the kind of National Security
implications are obviously huge
um I also wonder about it kind of from
the other direction like will our AIS
have
American values or American
personalities or something like that I
I'm sort of wondering about like not
only the effects but also
you know is there is there cultural
component to the type of AI we're going
to get or is that a math problem and
it's that you know it's wrong to think
about it as having this kind of human
overlay no so I think it's 100 so I
think it's 100 right and furthermore I
guess the way I would think about it is
if you look at the fight that's happened
over social media both in the U.S and in
China right over the last 10 years right
where both in the U.S there's been a
massive fight over like what values are
encoded into social media and like what
you know censorship you know controls
and what you know ideologies are allowed
to you know perpetuate and so forth
um like there's been a massive fight on
that in the US and of course there's a
constant running fight on that in China
right which is you know the great
firewall and they've got all their
restrictions on what they'll allow you
to show if you're a Chinese citizen and
then there's these cross-cultural
questions right which is this sort of
whole thing where people are wondering
it's like well you know Tick Tock is a
Chinese platform running in the US with
you know American users especially like
American children using it like you know
is you know a lot of people have
theories at least the tick tock is The
Tick Tock algorithm is very deliberately
steering us kids towards you know
destructive behaviors
um and is that you know some sort of
foreign you know basically uh you know
operation hostile operation and so
anyway like to the extent that these are
all big issues in this previous era of
social media I think all of these issues
magnify out by like a million times uh
in this AI area like all of those issues
become just like far more dramatic and
far more important and far more profound
um and the reason is just because user
generated content is kind of what we're
talking about like user generated
content on social media people only
generate so many kinds of content they
only engage on so many different kinds
of issues whereas AI is going to be
Universal like AI is going to be applied
to everything it's going to be involved
in everything it's going to be integral
to the Healthcare System it's going to
be integral to the you know just like
the financial system to education it's
going to permeate education
um right um and so it's going to be
relevant to but basically every field of
human activity where anybody can have an
opinion about anything
um and then yeah is that what you just
described is that a case for
um early and cautious regulation is that
a case for the impossibility of
Regulation where does that take us in
terms of what lawmakers could or should
be doing well what would a recent
magazine say about uh well-intentionally
you know the reason magazine well so
actually we're doing um a debate issue
coming up and we have
um we have a debate on regulation of AI
and there are people who are of course
deeply skeptical of governments who
still say well maybe they're maybe this
is the moment for guardrails you know
maybe at least we want to say we want to
limit how states can use AI for instance
um even if we don't want to live in
individuals
I mean I'll make your own argument back
to you um which I know you'll enjoy
right which is like you know the road to
hell right the road hell is paved with
good intentions
um you know you know everybody always
wants it's like boy wouldn't it be great
this time right if we could have like
very carefully calibrated well thought
through like rational reasonable right
like effective like regulation like
wouldn't that be great
like you know maybe this time we can
make rent control work right if we just
let you know if we just like if we just
if we're a little bit smarter about it I
mean I you know your own argument you
know your own argument obviously is like
well no that's not actually what you
know that's you know that's not actually
what happens right for all the reasons
you guys talk about all the time
um so yeah I mean look there's an
abstract theoretical argument for such a
thing we don't get the abstract
theoretical regulation we get the
Practical real world regulation you know
and and what do we get off the other
side right we get regulatory capture
um you know we get we get uh you know we
get we get corruption um you know we get
we get basically incumbent early
incumbent lock-in
um you know we get we get basically
political capture
um you know I mean we get we get we get
all the same you know we get we get
basically skewed skewed incentives um
and then you know years later we wonder
like how could we've done that to
ourselves and it's because everybody in
that moment said wow we really need some
sort of well-intentioned Regulation that
we can't actually get so I mean you know
look God bless you know I don't know
they'll probably try it again you know
this and then this is the other thing is
like you know is it is it good or bad
that our government is largely
dysfunctional um and you know generally
speaking can't pass legislation
you know the libertarian in me says you
know this is this is a case where
gridlock is good
um you know look the straight power
politics version of this is like we
can't even ban Tick Tock right like you
know American social media companies
aren't allowed to operate in China uh
the Chinese company is allowed to
operate in the US with total impunity
um you know you do look at the content
on Tick Tock that's going to kids in the
US and you do Wonder like what's going
on and there have been repeated attempts
right to block you know Tick Tock in the
US and they've all you know it's it's
still you know tick box is still running
in the US just fine so I don't know it's
like we we can't even ban Tick Tock you
know
um you know we couldn't you know we
couldn't effectively regulate the too
big to fail Banks you know we you know I
like Color Me skeptical but you know
yeah I'm sure they'll try
um you've talked a lot you're on record
talking about the quite rapid process
through which Innovative Tech startups
become kind of grumpy enmeshed
incumbents
um both just with the state and more
generally in their business practices
um that topic has come up a lot recently
with the Twitter files and you know the
sort of Revelations of the ways that
companies
um collaborated with uh willingly I
think in many cases but maybe with a
looming threat as well
um with government agencies around
misinformation and other questions
um it seems to me like we're going to be
in for more of that that this sort of
blurring of the lines between public and
private is Our Fate
um is that what it looks like to you and
if so you know is that ultimately a
thing that threatens Innovation or are
there ways in which it could potentially
speed things along
yeah so you know look the textbook view
of the American economy is that it's a
you know it's a it's a free it's free
market competition and like you know
companies are fighting it out and you
know different toothpaste companies are
trying to sell you different toothpastes
and it's a you know largely competitive
market and then every once in a while
there's an externality that requires
government intervention and then you get
you know these weird things like you
know the too big to fail Banks or
whatever but you know those are the
exceptions to the general working in the
free market system
you know like I can tell you my
experience having been now in startups
for 30 years is that the opposite is
true
um specifically that James Burnham was
right
um that we passed from you know the
original model of capitalism which he
called Bourgeois capitalism which is
what we still think capitalism is we
passed into a different model which he
called managerial capitalism uh you know
some some decades back
um and the the the actual correct model
of how the US economy works is it is
mostly a process of oligopolies cartels
and monopolies
um and they most it's it's mostly them
you know for it's basically big
companies forming up in an oligopolis
cartels of monopolies
um and doing all the things that you
expect oligopolis cartels and monopolies
to do
um and then they jointly basically
corrupt and capture the Regulatory and
government process and so they they end
up controlling their Regulators
um and so most sectors of the economy
are a conspiracy between the big
incumbents and their putative Regulators
um and the purpose of the conspiracy is
to perpetuate the long-term existence of
those monopolies and cartels and to
block new competition like so so that's
where that's where I've come out on
um to me that completely explains the
education system both K-12 and the
College University system it completely
explains the Healthcare System it
completely explains the housing crisis
it completely explains 2008 the
financial crisis and the bailouts it
completely explains the Twitter files
like I think that's precisely what what
has been happening in Tech
um and so if you're if you're if you're
if you're if you're open to that
interpretation of how the world works
and how the country works and how the
economy works then like a lot of things
start to make a tremendous amount of
sense
um and then you know I think that what
the Twitter files is is it's basically
an x-ray of a specific instance of that
happening
um which and this is just factual what
we now know from the Twitter files is
that a very large number of people in
government by the way some of them
political and you know some of them like
politicians but also some of them
bureaucrats right and so some of the
members of the right deep state right
which either you know as we know the
Deep State either does not exist or if
it does exist it's good right one or the
other
um I think most people ever yeah that's
what I've heard there's a recent book on
that that apparently makes that case
very very clearly
um so let's just say like the permanent
bureaucracy uh or again what James
Brennan would say is like the managerial
class in government right the sort of
permanent uh Cadre of Professionals in
government who basically manage
everything
um and you know those people and then
also people on the outside who they fund
as their proxies right with government
money with taxpayer money right have
been exerting enormous pressure
um on Twitter
um to block sensor dot dot dot dot you
know and and you know what looks to me
like a straightforward constitutional
case for a deprivation of constitutional
rights you know first fourth and fifth
amendments
um in a way that is clearly illegal both
under the Constitution and under uh is
it uh uh Title 18 uh whatever 242 uh you
know there's a specific federal law that
says there it's a felon it's a felony
for a government official to use the
power of being in government uh to deny
citizens of constitutional rights
um there's actually by the way another
law there's 241 that actually applies to
that same principle to private citizens
including private companies and so I
think it's possible that there has there
actually I think it's possible that
there's actually been criminal activity
both on the government side and on the
company side
um and yeah and it's just like yeah
that's been happening and you know the
Twitter for every new drop of the
Twitter files shows that that's what's
what's been happening you know in a in a
in a non-political world where we all
just like read the Constitution
um you know this would be a
constitutional crisis you know this
would be the biggest story in the
country there would be hearings you know
there would be you know among other you
know immediate impeachment proceedings
like you know this this would be a five
alarm fire right because obviously the
government can't be allowed to do this
um you know in our in our in our in the
real world of course that's not what's
happening
um and you know and we're back to either
either denial or or Embrace under the
theory that this is good and proper
right
um are there sectors that are less
subject to that Dynamic that you just
described in which the startup quickly
become the incumbent semester of the
state
I mean look so I think it's so my my
theory basically is it's the question is
always the same question like is there
actual competition right like so so
actually I think there's like a deeper
my deeper idea here is basically the
process of evolution like so the idea of
capitalism is basically an economic form
of the idea of evolution right a natural
selection and the you know survival of
the fittest and the idea that basically
it's a superior product ought to win in
the market
um and that markets ought to be open to
competition and a better you know a new
company can come along with a better
widget and take out the incumbents
because it's widget is superior and
customers like it better and so like for
for evolution to proper to to function
properly you need survival of the
fittest which means you need things to
die when they're not the best thing for
capitalism to work properly you need the
same thing to happen you need companies
to die when they are inferior to other
companies that are doing things better
right that that you know that's that
that's sort of inherent to the to the
thing and so the the question always is
like is there actual competition
happening or not right is is and you
know in part is like do consumers
actually have the ability to freely
select among the existing Alternatives
and then the other question is like can
can new can new products actually come
to market right you know can you can you
actually bring a new widget to Market or
do you get blocked out because the
regulatory wall that's been established
has been you know basically makes that
prohibitive I mean look the great
example of this is is banking right
where you know the big thing in 2008 was
we need to bail out these Banks because
they're quote unquote too big to fail
and so then there were screams of the
need to reform the too big to fail banks
that led to Dodd-Frank the result of
Dodd-Frank I call it the big Bank
protection act of 2011. uh right the the
result of that is that the too big to
fail banks are now much larger than
before
um and the number of new Banks being
created in the US has dropped to zero
right because it's now effectively
impossible to launch a new bank in the
U.S because you know JPMorgan Chase has
10 000 lawyers right working on their
regulatory issues and you have one like
it's it's not possible like you can't
start new Banks anymore
um and so anyway sorry so I'm I'm
repeating the uh I'm repeating the case
against um so but the question is like
where is that not happening like you
know where where in the where in the
market is that actually not happening um
you know where is there free in open
competition you know look the the
cynical answer is this it's not that
doesn't happen in the spaces that don't
matter right like so toys like anybody
can bring a new Toyota market like it's
fine sure great right anybody can you
know I don't know like anybody can open
a restaurant right it's I mean I just
say don't matter being like you know
these are fine and good like you know
consumer categories that people really
enjoy and so forth but as contrasted to
the healthcare system or the education
system right or the housing system right
or the legal your business if you want
freedom your business better be
frivolous I mean that would be that
would be the cynical way of looking at
it like if if it doesn't matter from a
societal structure right in terms of
like determining the power structure of
society and basically the power of the
government and Society
um then yeah go crazy do whatever you
want but like if it actually matters to
like major issues of policy right where
the government is intertwined with them
then of course it doesn't happen there
and again it doesn't happen there not
just because of the government it
doesn't happen there because of an
intertwining of the incumbents in the
government
you know look I I think this stuff is
getting look this is one of these things
where I almost have trouble debating it
I'm not debating with you but like
debating it with people who argue with
me on this because I think it's so
self-evident it's like well why aren't
there you know it's like why are all
these universities like identical like
why are all of the major universities
implementing the exact same like crazy
like why do they all have like identical
ideologies right why why isn't there
like a why isn't there a Marketplace of
ideas at the University level right and
it's like well that becomes a question
of like why aren't there more
universities okay well what and I can
tell you why there aren't more
universities there aren't more
universities because to be a new
University you have to get accredited uh
the accreditation
um uh Bureau is is run by the existing
universities
like it
it's sitting there in plain sight I'll
give you the other another example why
do Healthcare prices do what they do
right why why do Healthcare prices work
the way that they work a major reason
for that
um is because
um they because basically they're paid
for by Insurance um there's private
insurance and public Insurance the
private insurance Price is just key off
the public prices because Medicare
basically drives the whole thing because
Medicare is the big buyer
um so how are Medicare prices set
they're set by a unit inside HHS called
CMS
um and uh and CMS runs literal
soviet-style price fixing boards uh for
medical goods and services
um and so once a year there are doctors
who get together in a conference room at
like a Hyatt in Chicago somewhere
um and they sit down and they establish
they fix they do the exact same thing
that what was the unit of uh the the
Communist Party in the in the in Russia
that used to do this in the Soviet Union
um there's a term for it was the central
price fixing Bureau
um right so the Soviets had a central
price fixing Bureau it didn't work we
don't have that for the entire economy
but we have that for the entire
Healthcare System
right and it doesn't work for the same
reason that the Soviet system didn't
work right and so we've exactly
replicated the Soviet system we're
expecting better results it operates in
plain sight you can go on the CMS CMS as
a website they'll explain this all to
you it's operating in plain sight
everybody thinks it's a great idea and
then you know lots of people are calling
for you know increased government you
know centralized you know control and
purchasing of healthcare which would
make that system stronger and so it's
like we we know that this is not going
to work we know that it's going to only
result in restrictions of supply and
Rising prices we know precisely what the
outcome is going to be we seem perfectly
happy with it and then we complain about
it so
yeah yeah um I want to Pivot a little
bit and ask
um
sort of in this vein of you know
everyone is trying to build a system
that does good and they seem to want the
government to do it all the time but um
a little bit differently what has made
money for you or for your investors that
you think has also done the most to make
the world a better place
oh I I mean it's even hard to I mean we
all have we all have a narrative on that
like like what pick your favorite among
your all your children my narrative is
spectacular so um I mean look basically
material progress only ever happens
through technology like there's
basically only two ways to make material
progress on planet Earth there's only
two reasons why we're not all living in
mud Huts right and subsistence farming
all day which is what we used to do
right which is what our predecessors did
and there's only two reasons one is
natural resource extraction right um and
then the other is technology and and
those are the only two those are the
only two levers on the world right there
those are the only two ways to raise
standard standard of living it's it's
they're the only possibilities
um and so and you know natural resource
extraction is good up to a point but
like at some point you know at some
point you need to do something with the
resources and so that that immediately
also becomes an application of
Technology
um and so you know on the materialist
side right which is the obvious more
obvious one which is just standard of
living you know standard of living in
the US is up like 8X in the last you
know whatever it is 75 years or some
crazy number like that like it it is
true you know the engine of Technology G
routinely is producing you know
enhancements to standard of living and
of course there are the thought
experiments very easy which is you know
you know notwithstanding whatever
problems people have with you know
current modernity or post-modernity or
whatever we're living in like would you
switch places with you know your
predecessor 50 years ago you know from
from a material well-being standpoint
and you know the answer that for
basically everybody is is no and of
course we also know that because you
know you could build cities and towns
today if you wanted to where people
voluntarily you know didn't use
technology made after 1950 or something
and you know the Amish do that but like
you know nobody else does it
um and so you know material standards
are living um are you know continue to
advance
um I I think that that and I think
that's a perfectly fine and good
argument and then and then look I also
think the other side I've from in terms
of my My Philosophy there's like a human
Freedom right and and flourishing aspect
to it like the you know the sort of
intellectual or maybe even the spiritual
side and you know there's just like okay
like are people more free to like learn
and explore
um and express themselves and be
themselves and find like-minded people
right um and discover their calling in
life right
um and you know you know if they're
creating something bring their creation
to Market it and find the audience for
it or the market for it like you know
all of the like the ability of sort of
humans to self-actualize like is is that
expanding over time or diminishing over
time and it and I think like
overwhelmingly the impact of the
internet has been to expand that now
there is this you know giant War that's
happening where there's lots of people
who are trying to like shut that you
know shut aspects of that down and
control that but nevertheless I think I
think everybody would sort of have to
concede like the internet has made it
much more possible for a much broader
you know range of voices a much broader
range of ideas I mean I you know I read
and see things on the internet today
that like you know 25 years ago you know
you would have been in a card you know
you would you would have had to go deep
into the card catalog at some you know
giant University campus if you could
have gotten access to it to find some
book that was written in like 1820 or
something you know and today it's just
like tap tap tap Google search oh I can
you know I can find out I'll you know I
can find out all about this and then and
then I can write about it myself
um and so I yeah you know people people
it people actually do have like a much
greater level of let's say personal
freedom
um you know look have having said that
like the war to try to control that and
Chuck that off is also very real what do
you think is a better use of time and
resources trying to start a company or
giving away money to award the worthiest
cause oh I mean I think overwhelmingly
the former
um it's overwhelming with the former so
and this is and this is an argument
right that very very few people in our
modern you know kind of society modern
you know whatever
um civil religion are willing to make
but you know I'll make it which is
production is a good of itself right
like you know the person who makes your
toothpaste is doing you know the company
that makes your toothpicks is doing
something for you right that is superior
to that of you know most people doing
Health philanthropy right like it
production of the goods and services
that make our lives better um right and
and at the limit you know the goods and
services that like cure diseases and so
forth you know they're they're generally
for-profit companies the fact that they
make money on those things is just
reward for having improved the world
um you know I think most most of the
actual like material progress in the
world most of the most of the
Improvement in human welfare is done
through through for-profit production
um so so uh so I've I've I've I you know
I'm not you know there are people who
are like basically capitalism you know
building your company is a necessary
evil to generate the money with which we
can then make the world better I'm like
no that's not the case like most of the
good you're going to do in the world is
going to be through building your
company and then maybe you're going to
find a way to do some philanthropy thing
you know hopefully the philanthropy
thing that you do is not going to make
the world worse and that better which is
often an interesting question
um here's the other reason I believe
that so strongly which is
and again this let's assume some sort of
properly functioning capitalism right
with some level of effective competition
in the market you know production in the
for-profit system like the product
succeed or fail they're adopted or
they're not adopted on the basis of
whether people want them right and
whether people think that they make
their lives better and people want to
engage in that trade
um and so there's like there's like a
there's a there's a direct reality test
with every transaction right as to
whether this is actually something that
people want and whether this is
something that people think will will
improve their lives you know there is
this massive issue with philanthropy
which has always been an issue and it
continues to be an issue which is it's
just it's not subject to a market test
um and so and there are you know Reams
and Reams and reams of examples and
studies of philanthropic programs that
you know thought that they were gonna
you know you know lead to benefit you
know lead to some sort of beneficial
outcome in some area
um and then it turned out they you know
backfire horribly right and you know
there's an obvious one just kind of
staring us all in our face today which
is you know Criminal Justice Reform
right you know there's been this wave of
philanthropists many of whom I know over
the course of the last 20 years who have
you know spent an enormous amount of
money putting in place in New out of
politicians and a new set of political
ideas that have resulted in letting the
criminals out of jail and as a con you
know for justice and as a consequence
like crime is through the roof and it's
like not safe to be in the streets and
it's it's just like but like there's no
Market test like the the people who have
spent all of that money right to let all
the criminals out like they're not
subject to the risk of all the criminals
being out because they all have like
Navy SEAL Teams protecting them right
because they're all like rich
right um and so they're able to just
like arbitrarily like ruin Society um
you know through philanthropic efforts
with no corrective mechanism whatsoever
um and so I I you know if anything the
world we're in today like the dichotomy
between like the actual good at
production and then the actual evil of
sort of the unintended consequences of
sort of untested quote-unquote
philanthropy like I I think those are
gapping out in a pretty profound way
um again it's hard for me to even talk
about this with most people because I
just I think it's kind of obvious it's
like walk down the street in San
Francisco it's pretty obvious what's
happening and yet like the level of
denial among a lot of people I talked to
about this is like through the roof so
there's also the kind of
[Music]
um
I mean this sometimes shows up in the
kind of effective altruist critique
right where you say well you know why
why give to the Opera when people are
dying of malaria right that's the sort
of the previous effective outro is
critique I guess
um what do you give to if anything well
by the way the the malaria this goes to
the nature of the problem right the
nature of the philanthropy problem the
nature of the effect of altruism problem
which is right okay fair enough like
don't give to the Opera because people
are dying on malaria that's okay what do
we do to keep people from dying from
malaria well we give the bed nets right
and the bed nets are like treated with
chemicals that like you know prevent the
mosquitoes from from being able to um
you know to be able to you know to
spread malaria okay but now we've given
people you know Nets that are treated
with chemicals and then they turn around
and they use those nests to go fishing
but they use the you know there's and
then the chemical treatment on the Nets
ruins ruins ruins ruins the fishing
environment right like and now people
starve right and it's like by the way
maybe that happens and maybe it doesn't
but like it's happening 8 000 miles away
right in a way that you're never gonna
even know like what's happening and so
these like Cosmic big brain utilitarian
EA ideas that people are going to like
have have an Excel spreadsheet where
they're going to figure this stuff out
or they're going to sit on the cam you
know campus at Stanford or Oxford or
something and have these ideas that it's
going to translate into the real world I
mean my favorite example I'm sure you're
familiar with this but my favorite
example I keep trying to get all my
friends to read
um is the Moynihan report
um from 1965 so right Daniel Patrick
Moynihan wrote this report about the
rate of of a single uh Parenthood in the
U.S uh in 1965 and he sort of a lot of
social scientists will tell you like a
huge number of Life outcomes at the very
least correlate to whether you grew up
in a double parent or single parent home
um and so the one handing the money hand
was like the leading light of like the
liberal Progressive you know Reform
movement in 1965 with LBJ with a great
society and he had the full resources of
the government you know kind of limited
capability consultation with experts and
he wrote this report and it was like we
have this huge crisis because of the
percentage of of unwed uh you know
births um and then as a consequence
we're going to implement all of these
incredible programs both government
programs and philanthropic programs you
know to fix this and then fast forward
you know sitting here today 50 years
later
um you know the the the the percentage
of unwed versus tripled right and right
by the way with no accounting right like
with no accounting no accountability
he's dead he doesn't have to live with
the consequences nobody's looking at
this nobody cares you know maybe you
guys write a story on it or Fox News you
know somebody does it but like nobody
cares like and and those programs
continue on autopilot forever
um and so I I just you know I just find
it's like this remote control aspect to
it it's just like incredibly disturbing
uh it doesn't work but and again I go
back to this is the thing like any
business any for-profit business cannot
any legitimate for-profit business that
operates in a true competitive market
cannot do this
the market will prevent them from doing
this because if they do this the market
will stop the market will say no I do
not want you to do this anymore I will
not buy this thing anymore right and you
will go away right and there and there's
there's no equivalent pressure
whatsoever on a foundation or or a
philanthropist so so anyway what do we
do so specifically what we do is we
basically stick very very close to home
um and specifically what we do is
basically local social infrastructure in
particular we do emergency medicine
um and so we do um and and specifically
at uh at Stanford so um you know we we
basically fund Stanford emergency
medicine the whole program there
um and you know basically under under a
couple of theories number one is you
know whatever you feel about our health
care System it is true that at three in
the morning you know when your kid has a
fever of 105 or you know somebody you
know has a serious problem
um you know everybody's kind of equal
with the ER at three in the morning
um and so you know it is the ultimate
backstop for uh you know for medical
care for everybody
um and then the other is like any given
day I can go sit in in the ER and I can
see the patients right and I can see the
outcomes right and and I don't have to
wonder whether like this is a good idea
or a bad idea like I can see the benefit
like there's no remote control aspect to
it at all it's like it's like right
there
um it was like 10 minutes from my house
um and so you know that that's the kind
of thing we do and it's to at least try
to live up to the spirit of let's say
trying to make the world a better place
but also trying to do it in a way where
we can actually prove that we're
actually doing that
you know you said I think about 10 years
ago now
um that Bitcoin is as important as the
internet was
um and we've had a little time for that
to play out
um it's been tumultuous
um but I guess on the theme of This Time
It's Different
how is that prediction looking to you
you've done pretty well financially with
your investments in that space uh but
not everyone has
yeah well so there's a bunch of things
so there's a bunch of things in there so
so just the thesis of what I wrote then
which I still believe so the the I wrote
this piece as a New York Times column it
was a New York Times column back when
the New York Times would run things that
I write which by the way
because you're wondering is no longer
true
um but they ran it at the time
um and uh and so everything in there I
still agree with the one modification I
would make is I at the time it looked
like Bitcoin was going to evolve in
Bitcoin itself was going to evolve in a
way where it was going to be used for
many other things we at the time thought
it was a general technology platform
that was going to evolve to be to be
able to make a lot of other applications
possible in the same way that the
internet did in the same way the iPhone
did and so forth
um it actually turned out that didn't
that didn't happen but Bitcoin itself
just basically stalled out it basically
stopped evolving
um but what happened was a a bunch of
other projects emerged that sort of took
that place and the you know the big one
right now is ethereum
um is sort of the sort of the next
derivation and so if if I wrote that
thing today I would either say ethereum
is in a Bitcoin or I would just say
crypto you know or whip three instead of
Bitcoin but but otherwise it's all the
same ideas uh all the same ideas apply
um you know look the argument I made in
that piece that I 100 believe today is
basically the the and allow you use the
terms kind of interchangeably like
crypto web 3 blockchain or use those
terms kind of interchangeably
um they're the other the what I call the
other half of the internet the internet
they're they're the other it's the other
it's all the functions of the internet
that we knew that we wanted to have when
we originally built the internet as
people know it today and the web as
people know it today but it's all of the
it's all the aspects of basically being
able to like do business and be able to
have money and be able to do
transactions and have trust like we did
not know how to use the internet to do
that in the 90s and now with this
technological breakthrough of the
blockchain we now know how to do that we
have we have the technological
Foundation to be able to do that
um and so and and that there is
basically as follows which is basically
have a have a have a network of trust a
digital trust that that is overlaid on
top of the internet which is an internet
untrusted Network anybody can pretend to
be anybody they want on the internet
anybody can look after the internet do
whatever they want right it's famously
untrusted
um crypto web 3 it creates layers of
Trust on top of that and then within
those layers of trust you can represent
money but you can also represent many
other things you can represent claims of
ownership you can rep you know so you
can represent everything from house
titles car titles you know insurance
contracts loans
um you can represent claims to digital
assets you can have things like unique
digital art
um you can have
um you know all you can have a general
concept of like an Internet contract you
can actually strike contracts with
people online
um you know that they're that they're
actually held to
um you know it's just an example you can
have like internet Escrow Services like
so for e-commerce you can have a service
you have a two people buying you know
from each other you can have actually a
trusted intermediary now that is
internet native that has an escrow
service so so it's it's like basically
it's like you can build on top of the
untrusted internet all of the
capabilities that you would need to have
a full economy
um right in sort of the broadest
definition of that you you know there's
like a full Global Internet native
economy
um and you know that's a giant I mean
that's a giant idea you know the
potential there is is extraordinarily
High
um and so yeah we're you know we're
Midway through that process we have you
know funded and there's lots of others
but like there's tons of really smart
entrepreneurs who are basically going
after every aspect of what I just
described
um you know a lot of those things have
worked you know some of those things
haven't worked yet but I think that
they're going to work
um you know look having said that these
things are you know every new thing we
do is by definition you know it's called
venture capital for a reason like these
are Ventures you know you can add the
prefix A.D these are Adventures
um you know these are you know a big
question people always ask us is like
are you are you speculating and I'm
always like well I you know it's like I
don't even know what speculating is like
am I investing in something without
knowing how it's going to go yes is that
speculation yes is that every investment
yes like yes you know we're investing in
a future unknown State like you know
sometimes these things work sometimes
they don't sometimes the prices go up
sometimes the prices go down
um we never make price predictions
um you know we never predict that
bitcoin price or whatever is going to be
X or Y or Z at any given point I have
good friends of mine who still haven't
gotten the message on this and they
still call me up and they're like Mark
what's bitcoin price going to be next
month and I'm like I don't
beats me man you know go look in the
chicken and trails like I don't you know
I don't know what to tell you
um so the prices are going to whip you
know the prices whip around you know
through the process of the market trying
to establish value
um crypto looks more volatile than a lot
of other categories just because the
assets sort of lists publicly in advance
of you know when we back a private
company it usually doesn't go public for
if it goes public it'll go public like
seven or eight or ten years later
um crypto project crypto tokens start to
float much earlier than that so it's
it's almost as if startup Equity was
being traded to the public market from
the very beginning
you know of course those prices would be
highly volatile right a critique of
venture capital is that we present to
our investors people accuse us of
presenting to our investors what looks
like artificially uh suppressed
volatility because the prices of the
things that we invest in like in
actuality if they were trading on the
public market they'd be whipping all
over the place but we just hold them
privately we mark them once a quarter we
don't even know what they're worth then
we just let the accountants like make
some guess
um so whereas the crypto assets just
they trade publicly so um so so they
look more volatile I actually don't
think they're more volatile than the
other stuff that we do I think that this
is just all this is just the nature of
doing things that are new and
speculative
we never recommend people invest in
anything like if people want to invest
in crypto assets they should but they
should understand that the level of
volatility is going to be very high and
I think the same thing would be true of
anything quite honestly that they invest
in I want to talk about the kids these
days since you mentioned uh unwed
pregnancies and
um you know those numbers certainly like
teen pregnancy numbers recently are down
quite a bit
um some people take that as evidence
that maybe the kids are not all right
they're on their phones all the time and
they're not having human interactions or
something and so it's bad news that the
kids aren't having sex and doing drugs
um
what how are the kids these days are the
kids all right are you know you sort of
mentioned earlier education is one of
those sectors that is very very locked
down very very limited in terms of
innovation hard to break into
um
so how how are the kids doing and uh if
not well what can be done
well some of the kids are pretty messed
up like
I don't know if you've been noticing but
some of the kids seem to have some
issues so I will I'll concede up front
like there do seem to be some problems
um so let's see a whole bunch of things
in there um so yeah so so first off I'll
say like just the enormous irony I feel
like there's enormous irony so when I
was a kid you know so I'm I was a kid in
the 80s and when I was a kid it was this
constant like moral Panic
um constant media pressure of like the
kids were like totally out of control
right and it was it was literally like
the kids are all on drugs and the kids
were all having like casual sex and like
the kids are basically spiraling into
nihilism and and uh you know and sort of
self-destruction
um and so I will I will consider there
is a lot of irony to be sitting here
today and now there's this other
critique from the same at least the same
kind of person basically saying oh the
kids aren't doing enough drugs and
having enough sex and I'm like okay well
what do you want what do you want you
told us to stop doing those things and
we did okay so um yeah so look you know
there's there's deeper deeper questions
underneath that
um you know look the the birth rate
question I mean I I'm sure you know this
but like the birth rate thing like birth
rates are crashing all over the world
right so the most interesting thing
about the birth rate phenomenon
um and I think it's great that Elon you
know has been talking about this in
public and really elevating this because
it's a really big it's a really big
question
um but like birth rates are crashing in
the U.S birth rates are also crashing in
Europe and they're also crashing in
Japan and they're also crashing in Korea
and now they're also now crashing in
China and they're crushing and they're
crashing in Iran right and so like
whatever is happening is not happening
because of quote unquote you know
whatever American you know this that or
the other thing or even Western you know
or at least not like you know just kind
of facially like whatever is unique or
special or different about Western
culture like this is a broad-based
phenomenon you know I I you know I'm not
an expert in the thing um you know the
the sort of best analyzes I've read seem
to indicate that it's more or less a
natural consequence of you know much
much kind of a combination of like much
longer periods of Education uh sort of
coupled with much higher levels of
female engagement both in the education
system and in the workforce
um and if you sort of fully Empower
everybody both you know men and women to
kind of fully self-actualize in the form
of basically unlimited amounts of
Education coupled by unlimited
professional opportunities
um you basically it's like what I was
saying earlier it's like you just make
life more interesting for people
um in a way where you know they're
perfectly happy running through their
20s and 30s you know without the
obligations that come with having
children and then of course by the time
they decide they want to have children
you know if they're in their mid or late
30s it might already be too late
um so I I just go through that to say
like I don't even know is that good or
bad I don't know
um is it Western or Eastern it seems to
be both I mean the China One is
fascinating like you know the numbers
just came out the birth rate in China is
crashing even faster than expected you
know it it looks like they may already
have passed their demographic Peak
um right where we're from from here on
out the Chinese population may only age
right and by the way if you think we
have a you know to people to people who
think we have a problem with the birth
rate like the Chinese heavy the Chinese
have a real problem because like you
know it's one thing or you contrast like
Japan and China right like Japan has a
lot of old people but it's
extraordinarily wealthy Society
um because of all the economic
development developments that happened
between like 1950 and and uh and and the
present like into basically a society is
economically Advanced as ours or maybe
even more so
um you know China's not bad China's
still in the middle income Zone um you
know sort of 5 000 per capita GDP or
something like that
um there's no economics on Earth that
can explain how they're going to take
care of all their old people
um you know in the time frame that they
have to get ready for that um
so yeah this seems to be like a big
issue I mean look are we going to
reverse any of this like are we gonna
you know go back to a model where people
you know don't have all these years of
education you know maybe by the way
maybe we should we're probably not going
to
um are we gonna you know deprive you
know women of the professional
opportunities they have you know to go
back to an Era where they don't have
those opportunities probably not
um are we going to
um you know uh what else are we going to
become less you know you know sort of
socially Progressive
um and you know Elevate motherhood more
as sort of a social good problem you
know probably not
um that doesn't seem to be in the cards
um
you know another possibility here is are
we going to have scientific
breakthroughs right so you know this
this everything I've we've talked about
up until now is sort of assumed that
sort of the natural progress of human
birth and reproduction the old-fashioned
way
um you know look are we going to have
you know cloning of embryos are we going
to have you know external you know
gestation machines
um you know or are we going to be able
to are we going to have uh embryos
created by from stem cells right
um such that you know you you can you
know if you could you could decide on
your 60 it's time to have a new baby and
you could you know have it you have the
have the embryo cloned off your stem
cells and then have it you know have the
baby raised in a gestation tank for nine
months and the outcomes the other end
comes a baby like maybe
um is that you know are those
Technologies being developed now yes are
they going to freak people out yes
are they necessary for the perpetuation
of the species quite possibly yeah so
this this is kind of my Temptation
always is to say we are going to
technologically innovate our way out of
our sociocultural problems and it
obviously doesn't always work like that
but I mean you've said the future relies
on 19 year olds and the startups that no
one's ever heard of yet and those 19
year olds are gonna have to come from
somewhere right
um maybe we don't need to go all the way
to like growing them you know growing
them in a vet from stem cells but
it might help if what we need is kind of
peak weird 19 year old to get through
this right
yeah look there's that question and then
look there's another giant question
that's coming up right behind that which
is you know the the sort of the big
genetic engineering question right and
so like for example like this is not on
the horizon right now but like there's
very very you know
um uh Cutting Edge work happening in the
genomics field uh to identify all the
genes that are associated with
intelligence um right and there's it's
already we're up to like it's like we
already have up to like 200 genes
um that correlate to like half of IQ
um and so you know it let's just let's
assume we're moving into a world in
which we're increasingly going to be
engineering babies which I think is a
real possibility for the reasons we just
discussed
um are we also going to be optimizing
them right like are we going to be like
you know is there going to be a crisper
treatment that you can just dial up and
order in 10 or 20 years you know where
you can give your you know you can give
your stem cell you know clone uh embryo
a 20 or 30 point IQ boost right
right and so and so so maybe on the
other side of this are like you know
these sort of super babies right
um where we come out the other side of
this and we sort of technically engineer
ourselves you know not just the
perpetuation the species but like an
upgrade at the species where all of a
sudden the babies are all coming out
like much much smarter right um and then
you know as a consequence they're able
to you know do all kinds of things
better you know kind of through their
lives like you know so maybe there's a
technological Utopia on the other side
of this
um you know on the other hand maybe this
is some sort of catastrophic moral you
know philosophical civilizational
collapse right where we've given up on
sort of the inherent Spirit of what it
means to be human
um and we're gonna use you know we're
just in like terminal decline um and
we're you know we're going to use
technology so sort of the cyberpunk view
of it we're going to use you know
technology as sort of the Band-Aid you
know to kind of cover up what what
otherwise is kind of you know a hard
crash
right I I don't know like I don't know I
will say like these issues are real like
these issues are real and they're
forming up and you know everything you
and I just talked about like it's all
real it's all gonna happen
um and these are very big questions and
you know either people do not want to
talk about them today or if they totally
freak people out people get really mad
um so at least I I have yet to read or
hear a I don't know I guess what I would
say is a clear dispassionate
non-ideological like you know full
summation of all this like
people are bringing a lot of priors into
this conversation it's a little hard to
yes yeah yeah
um are those sectors where you think
um
where you think that there's currently
the right amount of investment
insufficient investment too much
investment because there's hype where
are we where are we there yeah so
probably Wilson investment so uh so um
so the real answer to the question is
there's actually two kinds of Technology
investment and they're actually very
different um so there's you know the
term that gets used to called research
and development but really those are two
different things so there's research and
then there's development and those are
those are two different things and so
the the research is basically funding
into scientific research and and
basically what that means is funding
into you know really smart people
pursuing like really deep you know
questions around technology and science
um you know such that you know they may
not even know what you know they may not
have any idea yet of what commercial
relevance or what kind of product could
get built on it or even whether
something can work right
um and so um you know so it's the
classic classic concept of basic
research
um and then there's the other side of it
which is what we do which is the
development side right um and so the way
we think about it is by the time we fund
a company to build a product like the
basic research has to be finished
already like there can't be open basic
research questions because otherwise you
have a startup that you don't even know
whether the thing will ever actually
you'll be able to even be able to build
a thing but then also like it needs to
be close enough to a commercialization
that you know within like five years or
something you can actually commercialize
it into a product so so anyways it's
sort of fairly well understood that like
those are the two sides of things um you
know that formula worked really well in
the computer industry um so there was 50
years of basically Government research
into information science computer
science
um you know during and after World War
II and then that translated to the
computer industry software industry
internet and that worked by the way that
also worked in biotech right and so that
worked for um you know NIH you know had
this big sort of sustained biomedical
research program that resulted in the
Biotech Industry which you know most
recently resulted in things like the
MRNA vaccine so like that worked
um you know those research programs
continue
um you know those are the two main areas
of I think actual productive research
happening so those are the two main
areas where we can get results out the
other side
you know should there be more funding
into basic research I mean almost
certainly um there should be um you know
look having said that the basic research
world has a very profound crisis
underway right now which is this let's
say they call the replication crisis uh
which is it it turns out that a lot of
what people thought was basic research
is actually just basically been fake
um and and arguably fraud and so there
there is a among the many problems that
our modern universities have there is a
very big problem or most of the research
that they're doing does seem to be fake
um and so you know it's like what would
you recommend more money to be put into
a system and this just generating fake
results no
um would you though argue that like you
do need basic research to continue to
get new products out the other end yes
so like that problem ought to get dealt
with um maybe it's starting to get maybe
it's starting to get dealt with very
slowly on the development side I'm
probably more optimistic I think yeah
generally like I would say generally we
don't lack for money which is to say the
Venture Capital industry like my
industry Venture Capital funding of
startups and funding of new tech uh like
I would say we as a sector have plenty
of money there's plenty of investors who
want to invest
um you know the companies seem to get
perfectly well funded
um I think basically all the good
entrepreneurs get funded
um I think that um you know all the good
companies get funded I I don't think
there's a shortage of money there
um the main question on that side of
things is not so much the money the main
question goes back to our question about
competition and how markets work which
is in what fields of economic activity
can there actually be startups right
um and so and specifically for example
like can you actually have education
startups can you actually have
Healthcare startups can you actually
have housing startups
um well they can you actually have
Financial Services startups can you
actually can you actually do a new bank
like can you do a new online bank that
like Works in a different way and you
know for for those fields where you
would want to see like a lot of progress
the bottleneck is not whether we can
fund them the bottleneck is literally
whether the companies will be allowed to
exist
um and so on that side of things that
that that's what I would focus on
yeah I think there are sometimes places
where you might have said listen it's
settled wisdom that you can't have a
startup in this area
um and then it turns out you can and I'm
thinking here I guess of space
um I'm thinking of
um you know maybe to some extent in um
some subsets of education and of course
also
um I would put crypto in this category
you know what how can you compete with
money
um and then here we are uh in a quite
robust competitive market that is trying
to compete with money
um what how do you how do you go from
actually competition doesn't look very
possible in that space to
someone tries it yeah so SpaceX is
probably the best you know SpaceX is
probably your best case scenario can we
talk about crypto also as an example but
like let's just take SpaceX as an
example right so you know I mean talk
about a market that's like dominated by
the government and like has regular
regulations to the Moon literally to the
Moon
um right like you know uh you know there
has not you know it's one of these
things or have not now I don't even know
the last time anybody tried to do a new
launch platform
um and then the idea that you're gonna
put all these satellites up there like
there's massive regulatory issues around
that so um and then just like the
complexity you know on top of that you
know you he you know Elon wanted the
Rockets to be reusable so he wanted them
to like land on the rear ends right
which is like something that people
thought was impossible right um you know
all previous Rockets you basically
they're they're one shot and they're
done
um whereas his Rockets get reused over
and over again because they're able to
land themselves
um and so yeah I mean look at SpaceX
climbed a wall of um you know skepticism
its entire way and like he basically
just like brute forced his way through
it and you know he and the team there
made it work
um and so that that you know that that's
that's the best case scenario there
there is a Playbook that he used which
we have you know now now that now that
he's done that to give him full credit
you know we've studied that Playbook and
so we're attempting to replicate it
um in other fields um you know the big
thing we talk about there in our
business is just like is that you know
look that is a much much harder
entrepreneurial Journey right like that
that's just like the the what the
entrepreneur has to sign up for to do
that like and the risks that are
involved are just like much harder uh
but like you know for example starting a
new software company or something
um and so it's just a much higher bar of
like competence that's required um it's
just much higher risk you're going to
lose more of those companies because
they're just going to like not be able
to make it they're gonna get blocked in
some way and then you you need a certain
kind of founder who's willing to take
that on and that founder looks a lot
like an Elon Musk or by the way it looks
like a Travis kalanick right or it looks
like an Adam Newman right or it looks
like uh you know you know these are the
you know or or by the way in the past it
looks like Henry Ford right um you know
these this requires you know a till of
the Hun
Alexander the Great Genghis Khan right
these are the you know to make that kind
of company work require somebody who is
so smart and so
um determined and so aggressive and so
Fearless right and so resistant to
injury in many different kinds right and
so willing to take on just like
absolutely Cosmic levels of vitriol and
hate and abuse right and security
threats and all the other crazy stuff
um like and so you know speaking of
growing people into like we need more of
those people I I wish we could find a
way to grow them in tanks we don't know
how to grow them in tanks you know we
spend a lot of every day in our day job
trying to find those people you know it
is we call the the problem the missing
elons right it's just like you know we
need 10 more elons and then we need 100
more elons and then we need a thousand
more elons
and it's just like I can just tell you
like there there are not many elons
running around running around
um and you know and Eli like Elon you
know people have like as you you well
know but like people have all kinds of
reactions to Elon like you know uh like
these people put up with you know now
look elon's been very successful he's
made a lot of money and so forth but
like he puts up a lot of from a lot
of people on a lot of topics that would
cause most people to melt into a little
puddle
um and so this this is like the highest
engagement I mentioned the top the Top
Gun story uh the Top Gun movie so Tom
Cruise once said he said there's Tom
Cruise wants to have this great quote he
said there's there's only it was he said
there's only four professions uh that
are really that are really like fully
masculine um that are that like real men
should actually pursue and as he said
it's a fighter pilot rock star movie
star and president of the United States
um right so you know in theory he's done
three of those
two of those three three of those of you
caught the movies
because it depends on how you count
um certain other people maybe have done
more of those
um uh
you know maybe the fifth is you know
high octane entrepreneur right operating
in a regulated industry who just is
determined to just like punch through
the walls you know you know category
number five is Elon and and so anyway I
just say like this is the pro like in
our world this is the prize like this is
the prize we wake up every day hoping
the next Elon walks through the door
generally we get very smart
entrepreneurs walking through the door
they're really good at what they do but
they're not the next Elon every once in
a while they ask us what would it take
to be the next Elon and I describe what
it would take and they you get this like
increasingly disturbed look on their
face and then they kind of decide they
don't want to do that is this kind of
the classic like oh if you have to ask
the price you can't afford it situation
well there's this question then which is
like are these people like it was you
know keep going to the Elon example like
you know you know nature versus nurture
right you know was he you know was he
was he born that way was he trained that
way right culture
um you know
um you know you know for sure he's like
you know super smart
um you know there's a big nature
component of that he's super
disagreeable uh right he's maybe the
most disagreeable person on the earth on
planet Earth right now and that there's
a big uh you know kind of nature
component to that
um but then look at you know he he you
know he's he's articulated his life
story like there are plenty of things
that happen to him that caused him to
develop an incredibly thick shell and to
be incredibly determined and to not want
to give up on things
um and so you know a lot of that
probably came from his you know cultural
you know sort of cultural culturated
kind of experiences uh traveling through
life um and then you know look part of
it's just like simple flat out
determination like he just applies
himself
um you know with a level of effort and
focus
um you know and just every day
um you know he works Around the Clock
like it's really amazing uh to watch um
you know you know I mean we're used to
Workaholics and he's like at a whole
different level
um
and so um you know I don't know yeah
could you know could you take more
people who kind of have the right you
know the right stuff you know in terms
of being smart and disagreeable and
intense and could you train them up
better
probably you know you know we try that
you know that is kind of what we try to
do
um you know that said like you know
there's something special going on there
why do you think it is that there is
this kind of special category of
like obsessive anger that's directed at
particularly the entrepreneurial
billionaire I mean we're talking about
you know U.S senators tweeting
billionaires should not exist right like
this is it's sort of it's very
acceptable to say it's a widely shared
view
um
where does that come from why is it why
is that like a meme in our culture
yeah so I think it's all in Nietzsche to
be totally honest I think it's it's what
he called resentment
um which basically is it's basically
it's it's it's what he called the toxic
blend of resentment and vegan bitterness
um and so it's it's it's sort of you
know it's the Cornerstone of sort of
modern culture right it's the
Cornerstone of Marxism it's the
Cornerstone of you know progressivism
it's you know it's the Cornerstone kind
of thing which is like we was at you
know we resent people who are better
than us
um you know different societies have
different Christianity too right yeah
Christianity you know the Lash will be
first and the first will be last you
know a rich man you know you know will
sooner pass through the I have a needle
then enter the kingdom of God right like
you know you know Christianity is is you
know is sometimes described as sort of
the final religion you know Christianity
is described sometimes as the final it's
the last religion that can ever exist on
Planet Earth because it's the one that
appeals to victims
um and the nature of life is there are
always more victims than there are you
know winners um and so the victims are
always the majority and so therefore one
religion is going to capture all the
victims or all the people who think of
themselves as victims or want to
identify as victims
um and you know that by definition is
the majority
um you know among lower class societies
sometimes you know lower class you know
social science I'll sometimes refer to a
phenomenon called crabs in a bucket
um we're in a lower class environment if
one person starts to do better the other
people will drag them back down right
you say this is like a big problem in
education in Lower Class environments um
and one kid starts to do good and the
other kids start to bully him until he
is going back you know until he's no
better than the rest
um Scandinavian culture you know that I
come out of uh you know there's a term
tall poppy syndrome right
um you know the tall poppy gets whacked
you know the the top pop you're growing
in the field you know gets gets gets his
head cut off
um you know the Japanese have their own
version you know this again is it's
almost like a cross it's like a very
deep human nature thing it's basically
just at the very deepest level it's envy
and resentment uh and and then and you
know the the nature of envy and
resentment is like
they're very satisfying feelings like
you know resentment's like a drug right
like resentment is a very satisfying
feeling because it's the feeling that
lets us off the hook
right like if I could resent somebody
else then I then it's not my fault it's
their fault not my fault I I I'm not bad
they're bad right and if they're more
successful than I am it just proves that
they're worse than I am right because
obviously they must be immoral they must
have committed crimes they you know they
must be making the world worse um you
know they must be a destructive force
and so yeah I know it's look it's it's
very very deeply wired in
um you know uh
I guess I'll say this you know the
entrepreneurs the best entrepreneurs we
deal with they have no trace of it at
all
um you know the best entrepreneurs we
deal with you know with just these
things the entire concept is just
absolutely ridiculous like why would I
spend any minute thinking about whatever
anybody else has done or whatever
anybody else you know thinks of me like
that's crazy like I'm just gonna I'm
gonna make progress in my whole life
today and the rest of the rest of what
people think doesn't matter
um but you know the very nature of it I
mean you know look you know you should
call to slavery slave morality right
which is you know the morality of the
slave and of course the irony of slave
morality is slave morality is you know
in the modern world is is taken on
primarily by people who are not actually
slaves right and so it's people who are
choosing to have the morality of the
slave even though they actually are they
even though they actually are free to
also not do that
um and you know if you're if you're
immersed in that world or you've been
brought up in that world or you've been
trained into that World
um or it's reinforced your National
inclination to be in that world it's
it's really hard you know the the
message that comes across that says no
actually no actually the things that are
going wrong in your life are not because
other people are doing better this
because like you're spraying everything
up like you know who wants to hear that
um what are you reading watching
listening to and um what do you think
what what new-ish book is being slept on
right now what's a newish book that is
good and underappreciated
uh let's see well so I mentioned Burnham
so I and I can't help myself so um for
anybody wanting to kind of really
understand
um kind of this like the thing we were
talking about earlier about like the
different models of capitalism
um you know so there's kind of two
really key James Brennan books uh one is
called the managerial Revolution
um which uh uh you know kind of
describes the the sort of evolving shape
of capitalism through the 20th century
which I think is probably the best
explanation for what happened to get us
where we are and then there's another
book called the machiavellians um which
is about kind of the structure of
politics and Society uh in in the sort
of you know sort of democratic World
um so those are really good um on on
Nietzsche so um I've actually been
reading my way all the way through both
Nietzsche and schopenhauer which is very
interesting but um there's a small book
on the topic of resentment we were just
talking about uh there was a philosopher
in the 1910s 1920s named Max Schaller
who wrote a book called resentiment
um r-e-s-s-i uh resentment r-e-s-s-i
intimate
um and
um he he basically it's a short book uh
it's on Amazon and he he basically
describes Nietzsche's theory of every
sentiment uh which we just talked about
and then he sort of elaborates on it um
and uh and and that that's really you
read that book and you're like oh my God
like yes I'm surrounded by people just
like that
um so there's that one um what else
um
uh
let's see give me a second here
um I just read uh have you run into um
John Murray Cudahy no if you're into
this guy so I just read his two books
very obscure very well they're both
online you can get them both online on
the internet archive but um there's
there's sort of posting they're sort of
post nietzschean they're actually sort
of on the same topics uh it's it's
basically they're they're on the topic
of basically what happens when different
societies basically Clash
um when when societies encounter each
other and then some societies are more
developed than other societies like some
societies are more like materially
prosperous than other societies and
basically like what is the reaction that
happens from that and what are all of
the different like coping mechanisms and
changes that happen as a result so
history books are both fantastic uh from
the 1970s so I'd recommend both of those
uh more recent books
um
okay I'll give you two I'll give you two
that I think are sort of flip sides of
this very interesting some some of the
topics we talked about earlier so two
books on sort of the past and future of
humanity that I recommend so the sort of
culture book is uh Joseph Henrich
um uh wrote the book on what he calls
weird
um which is uh is the book's called the
weirdest people in the world and and
weird is This Acronym of Western
educated industrial rich and Democratic
um and Henrich is like the the leading
Anthropologist of his generation and he
he came up with this very interesting
breakthrough which is he came up with a
way to actually critique different
cultures but without being called racist
um or bigoted or xenophobic and the way
that he did it was he came up with his
acronym weird to describe our culture
um so it so it sort of is this like
basically this little mechanism that he
uses where like who can get mad at him
for calling all our culture weird
um like he sounds like he's being
self-critical but but what he's actually
doing is it's actually a very
interesting kind of uh x-ray of the
process of cultural development both in
the west and swear that's really
interesting and you know there are still
huge cultural uh you know differences
all around the world
um that uh you know that are still very
relevant that he goes through in a lot
of detail
um it's probably it's probably the best
work of like cultural analysis written
since like probably I don't know the
1950s or maybe 1930s or something
because he figured out a way to actually
kind of talk a little bit more openly
about it
uh I've read that and I really did not
think when I opened it up that I was
going to be learning that much about
cousin marriage uh but it turns out
that's a big one in there cousin
marriage cousin marriage and is okay so
we'll do a minor spoiler so cousin
marriage um uh turns out to be a really
big deal because societies that have
cousin marriage basically cousin
marriage is the mechanism for the
perpetuation of a tribal Society
um and so the way that tribes perpetuate
and basically maintain sort of the
coherence of the tribal identity
um and the tribal kind of feeling the
way that they do that is basically
through because of marriage they
basically have enough intermarriage
among cousins where the tribe sort of
the the barrier between the tribe and
the rest of the world actually kind of
remains intact
um and then the theory that he goes
through is basically what what what
happened in the west that caused the
West to diverge you know with the
Enlightenment and with modern Economic
Development and scientific development
and everything else has happened the
last 500 years the thing that caused the
West to change and become what it is
today is that the Catholic Church banned
cousin marriage
um in Europe
um which they did for their own
self-interest they did because it turns
out they wanted the money in his theory
um they wanted to be quests uh they
wanted the money they didn't want money
to the Catholic Church did not want
money to stay in families uh it wanted
the families to basically fracture over
time so that the money would go back to
the church but the result of that was
like in his argument that was the the
change in human Affairs that led to the
Europe transitioning from being a tribal
Society to what it is today uh which you
could call an enlightened Society you
could call it atomized Society right um
you know it led to the rise of the
concept essentially the modern concept
of the individual
um you know which is still an alien
Concept in a lot of tribal societies so
so that one's really interesting and
then um and then the the sort of other
the flip side of that on the sort of uh
uh sort of genetic side which is super
interesting is this book called uh who
we are and how we got here
um which is this uh it's a Harvard
Professor David Reich uh who runs the
leading lab that does uh this work in
archeology called ancient DNA
um where it turns out we now have the
science to basically find like a
skeleton that's thousands of years old
and the the scientists actually know how
to extract DNA
um and actually analyze and actually
analyze the DNA and this you know this
is like a huge breakthrough in
archeology for obvious reasons
um and so Reich is Reich is Reich in his
lab at Harvard are actually
um uh they're actually building out the
actual the actual Human family Tree
um so the actual like genealogy of the
human race
um and well and it's what the book is
called who we are and how we got here
like it literally is like the actual
genealogy of the human race like where
all these people came from like how we
all got descended from whatever we got
you know all these questions and then
how all the populations developed and
how they intermixed or how they didn't
intermix and so forth um and uh it's
just like I just found that to be like
absolutely it feels like an x-ray
machine into the ancient world
um uh it's through science through
Modern Cutting Edge science that I found
completely unexpected oh and then I'll
add one final book which is the best
book on occults that I've ever read
which is also relevant on the same
thread which is the ancient city
um which is this book that was written
in the 1860s uh by this French scholar
at the time and um it's sort of uh it's
actually it's actually interesting it's
he was he he used a literary method so
this guy in 1860s basically apparently
read all original Greek and Roman
Literature Like apparently read all of
it
um and then he derived from it basically
what human civilization was like before
the Greeks and Romans
um and so what it was actually like to
basically be in a tribe uh or be in a
family to be in a tribe or be in a city
um in like you know two thousand three
thousand BC 4000 BC 5000 BC and then
sort of the changes that happened over
time and then and then what what
actually happened when Greece and Rome
arrived
um and and if you read those three books
together you you it's like you you get
this kind of cultural analysis side
um you get this archaeological analysis
side and then you get this like literary
analysis side of like painting a picture
of what the world used to be like
um which is not like the world is today
um and it's actually been very helpful
for me to understand what the world is
like today kind of as a as a as a
derivation of of how people used to live
then
um anyway among other things that the
ancient city talks about is it talks
about the critical role of the cult
um and um the religion basically the the
cult literally being a religious cult
literally being like the foundational
model for for human lives prior to what
we now know as religions
um and so also if you find yourself in
the business of wanting to create Cults
it it turns out to be a good book you
know there are days it's tempting
um so you know at that same point 10
years ago when you were making that
prediction I a perhaps naive libertarian
um had a lot of hopes that
um that these Technologies would be
would finally be the thing that um that
took a bunch of our Commerce and a bunch
of our networks of trust outside of the
realm of the state or at least another
degree removed and I think
some of that was punctured quite quickly
you know this idea that Bitcoin is
anonymous right which was just never
true
um but I I wonder what your
what your sense is of whether ultimately
there is still that kind of liberatory
element to these Technologies is there
is there good reason to think that we
will live in a Freer society when some
of these things come to fruition or do
we take the uh the cynical realists view
that The Regulators always have their
way
yeah so I think I was I think economic
freedom I think you can I think you can
make that argument so quite strongly um
political Freedom you know maybe maybe
not
um so the economic freedom argument is
just like it's the same argument you
make on the internet which is like are
people more economically free on the
internet than they used to be in an old
world of just having stories and I think
the answer is clearly yes like people
have the ability to offer goods and
services much more broadly they have the
ability to buy from many more places you
know uh transparency of what people you
know are buying is is much greater now
than it used to be um you know
reputation matters more than you know
just you know whatever happens to be on
the store shelves
um so and and then you know people can
transact in you know categories of goods
and services that maybe would have been
hard to get at the past you know so
there's a whole bunch of like economic
freedom arguments um does that translate
to political Freedom
um you know so the state
there's a couple things right the state
is sort of obvious but just make the
argument right so this the state does
have like one fundamental thing that's
just hard to get away from which is it
just it has territory like it has
physical territory and then it has the
ability to tax on that territory
um and so to the extent that you need to
live anywhere um you're going to be
living someplace and that place is going
to want you know its share of your
economic out you know your economic
output and they're going to show up you
know the tax collector is going to show
up when the tax collector shows up he's
going to want to get paid in his
currency right and so we'll Begin by
having a body it precisely exactly so
the taxi if you're in the U.S the tax
collector is going to want US dollars if
you're in France the you know the tax
collector is going to want whatever
currency they use these days
um and
um you know so I I do believe like
there's all these there's all these
theories of what makes money money
um and uh one of the theories I like is
John Law's Theory which is money is that
which people trade with
um and the theory there basically is
people will always find some sort of
thing some they'll always find something
whether it's cow shells or script
currency or or us US dollars or diamonds
or art or Bitcoin that felt to trade
with right so money has facilitation for
trading I do believe that
um but having said that there's another
theory of money as money is that which
The Sovereign taxes you for
um because you need to get whatever that
is you need to get some of that like
even if you want to live in an all
Bitcoin world in the US today at some
point you need to convert to dollars
because you need to pay your taxes and
the the IRS does not take Bitcoin
um so so I kind of think those are both
pretty pretty solid solid theories and
and to me those kind of argue for both
sides of it which is yeah you're going
to have systems that are going to
facilitate trade that are not
necessarily you know the US dollar or
the Euro or the Yen you're going to have
you know you're going to have online you
know alternatives to those and you do
today and look Bitcoin has been trading
and being used for transactions
continuously every minute of every day
since 2009 right um and so like those
are going to exist
um but at the same time like yeah we do
have physical bodies at least for now
we're gonna be rooted some place at
least for now the tax collector is going
to show up at least for now
um you know look there's big outstanding
regulatory issues right now in the whole
Space
um you know there's the and we're here
we're back to the original regulation
discussion that we had which is just
like there's tons of push and pull
there's lots of people who think that
there ought to be more regulations you
know in this space there's tons of
people who think that there shouldn't be
um there is the theory of enlightened
regulation that will achieve the results
that The Regulators intend and then
there's the reality of the unintended
consequences that always come with it
we're back to that exact same you know
dynamic in crypto regulation you know
sitting here today both in the in the US
and around the world
you know I don't know like and then
there's like you know another way to
think about this is like you know this
is constant you know the surface level
kind of question is always just well
aren't they just going to ban it right
like so they just ban Bitcoin and then
it's like well how do you ban Bitcoin
um it's like it's it's an algorithm like
it's it's an algorithm which means it's
a mathematical formula
um the source code for it is available
for free anybody can download and run
that source code on their computer
um you know for the government to ban
you know for a government to ban Bitcoin
you know they literally are putting
themselves in a position where they're
they're banning math
you know they're banning code
um you know like they can try
um you know the the the level of of I
would say the level of tyranny required
to ban math
um is I think way in excess practically
speaking of what governments are either
capable of doing or actually want to do
like the North Koreans can probably do
it I I don't know that I don't know that
our government would be allowed to do it
even by people who think that this stuff
should be regulated
um so uh yeah you know look I think
there's going to be some Running Room
for for Innovation here
um I also make a very different argument
on this which a lot of people respond to
which is look
this is a technology of the future like
at least like those of us who are those
of us whose day job it is to like
identify Technologies of the future and
help build them like this is one of
those like everybody everybody in my
world who's like really smart they're
all like yes this this is a technology
in the future what exact shape it takes
is is open question but yeah this is a
big deal uh 30 years from now this is
going to be a really big deal um and and
a lot of the smartest computer science
people in the industry have gone into
this field and are working hard on
making it work and making it better
um and then it's like okay if there is
going to be a technology of the Future
Would it's back to the question you
asked about AI earlier
um would we like that technology the
future to be built and developed and
housed in the United States
um or would we prefer to drive it
offshore you know to other places
um and actually Rishi sunak in the UK
just came out with a very supportive uh
statement policy basically essentially
saying if U.S Regulators don't want the
stuff in the US then everybody's just
come to the UK and do it there you know
so so maybe there will be an escape
hatch to the UK you know maybe to
Singapore or someplace like that
um
you know or or you know I don't know or
or people will come to their senses and
understand that they should you know
this is something the country should
actually invest in and support
or there will be attempts to regulate it
and they just won't work well and I I
don't know uh you know those are all a
good questions right now
um this was great is there anything else
that you think reason readers should
know
what
message do you have for the people yeah
I mean I don't know here would be
something it's just like
yeah I would say try the new stuff right
like you try it right like you know find
a friend you know find a friend who has
a Tesla and you know to go take it for a
ride with the full self-driving turned
on right or like you know chat chat you
know log into chat GPT online and like
log in and create an account try it or
you know you know try try a uh yeah just
like you know these things you know
these most of these things you can just
like go online on either for you know
trivial amounts of money or no money you
can just try and use
um I was just you know there's there's
just oceans and oceans and oceans of
commentary on this stuff you know not
not you guys but like from lots of other
sources and like for most of it it's
just you know we we out here just like
Shake our head being like these people
haven't even used this stuff like that
you know they're they're debating
Shadows on the cave wall you know this
is a long-standing uh point that we make
about guns there's a lot of people who
have never shot a gun who have a lot of
opinions about guns
every time you read about like you know
automatic pistols right it's like
you know it's like okay go shoot a
pistol
hold the trigger down let's see what
happens
um yeah exactly so um yeah I look the
tech industry the tech industry used to
be top down so the tech industry used to
create products for like the government
first and then big company second and
then small companies third and then
regular people fourth and in the last 20
years that's reverse the tech industry
now everything new that matters comes
out for people first it's it's it's it's
the consumer markets lead and then it's
like years later big companies and
governments start to figure out how to
deal with this stuff and so anything new
and interesting is something that you
can literally just log on and try
um and um it's all it yeah the waters
yeah the water is warm
um on this end of the pool like this
stuff is actually stuff is actually
pretty cool
thank you for talking to reason yeah
awesome thank you for having me
[Music]